was it always gonna be a quiet place
part 2 or did you have another title um
no it was always a quiet place part 2
cuz it was actually um my wife when she
read the script for the first time she
said what I loved most about the movie
is it doesn't feel like a sequel it
feels like the second book in a trilogy
of books and I said oh wow that's really
good and I said that I had already
thought of part two and when she said
that I said so I'm I'm allowed to put
part two and not feel like a total
poseur her to put part two and so um no
I I do I feel like the movie really
feels like an actual continuation of the
first one not just a not just a plug
line of like it's a continuation of the
first one completely um when the movie
ended I was a little bit pissed because
I wanted more good this exactly and you
want people to be pissed right so no no
you know what I mean no I know but like
you mentioned that part two of a trilogy
maybe I mean I hate asking this but like
as a fan of this material and what
you've created have you thought about a
third one it's interesting I hadn't
thought about a second one when I was
doing the first one however I really had
these questions while I was doing it
like I put the fires out in the distance
in the first one and I always thought to
myself wouldn't it be cool if we got to
explore where those fires lead to who's
on the other end of those fires but I
never thought that there would be a
sequel so then when I actually came
around writing the sequel I started with
the fires and so this time I think when
my brain started wandering of questions
about what would this mean later on I
started to write down notes in case I
could prepare myself for a third one
though I don't know I mean you know as
much as I do whether or not there's a
third one I think it's gonna make a lot
of money and the Paramount will call you
on it's Saturday morning have them call
you and then you call me we'll go over
it